you
was she a good storyteller she was
always a good conversation she was a
great listener and and could describe
things really well
something Ben it happened and she was
fun but I think she's saved the story
because you could tell she was always
working should I be looking up
a lot of the time she just wasn't quite
there english was in her we
imagination it's because this seems to
be the thing she was everybody else
talks about very gooey those were and
writing but it seems like she did it
story all right I think so i think she
was always brewing something so where do
you think this urge peaceful well when
she was little I think 17 she was a
voracious reader and read a lot of hands
Christian Anders
whatever is available and she it was so
so real to her she just she wanted to
change the endings you know she wanted
to to make things happen in the world
with words it was almost a magical power
I think
making stories has been a whole life
the no she says she wants to stop right
thing to live her life without the sperm
so I guess must have cost her something
the burning thing yes well it did
consume her as i'ma say she was very
passionate about it but also dispassion
I think she held back energy may be fun
things other people do in the world so
that she could create the things she did
she was she would conserve her energy
and so she often seem not to be you know
in the world as as other people are so
the view I mean I always respected it
I'd learned that she really liked it if
you were quiet around her you know was a
good time at home and she managed to
write she's very disciplined she'd read
from 10 till noon
every day so we didn't really feel like
we were interfering
it was just some other part of her that
was often inaccessible do you really
think that you were quit writing you
were shaking your head not responded I
don't think she'll ever be like other
people as she's trying to you know she
might be trying to ease into that world
but I really dug it I think she'll be
making them up even if she's not writing
them down